[Musique]
quand on passe au saumurage on laisse
aussi souvent à la dinde mais plusieurs
autres viandes mériterait ce traitement
le plus elle n'en valent la peine d'être
mur et à mon avis c'est beaucoup de
viande et voilà même des poissons on va
chercher à cuire la plus haute
température fait 55 degrés Celsius en
degrés Celsius il se passe quelque chose
en effet il y a beaucoup de contractions
et
que l'eau dans un muscle et
le sel et
normalement il
est
Laden par exemple qu'on fait cuire
pendant plusieurs heures par énormément
d'eau et ça sèche si elle n'est pas
d'abord saumurée
sa structure musculaire avec les clés
sont quand même assez coriace et quand
on veut cuire longtemps et et on peut
aller chercher un énorme au niveau avec
avec une somme
il y a un autre problème qui survient
c'est que c'est souvent un animal qui
quand même assez important au niveau de
son volume de sa masse donc pour que le
sel pénètre à cœur c'est très très long
généralement on parle de 1,9 centimètres
par jour de pénétration
on parle de plusieurs jours au frigo
pour un petit poulet comme ça d'un kilo
et demi environ je sonnerai aussi pour
24 heure au frigo à dans de l'eau à 50
grammes de sel par litre moi je mon
poulet rôti de 10 ans et toujours Saumur
et à la maison systématiquement mais
mais plus petite pièce de perdrix de
pintade de même de suprême de canard à
la lumière du Valais le sont aussi
pour nous a fait l'expérience de Saumur
et de la pintade et des suprêmes de
canard qu'il ensuite fait cuire sous
vide afin de les comparer avec des
pièces identiques non Saumur et pour le
canard la saumure et sèche donc le sel
et saupoudrer uniformément sur la pièce
de viande
j'ai cuisiner deux suprêmes de canard
qui était Saumur et à 1 pourcents à 7 %
de la masse du sucre de canard
saupoudrer pendant 24 ans merci c'est la
pièce Saumur et la pièce de canard
Saumur et à conserver plus d'humidité
que celle non Saumur et au niveau des
qualités sensoriel une belle couleur
capote de l'eau qui s'écoule non plus
parce que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
le maintien de l'humidité dans le
produit à on voit quand même une très
grande différence ici ça reste quand
même relativement juste selon les
paramètres de cuisson qu'on a pratiqué
entre l'eau et la fibre
initialement mais après
même exercice avec la pintade
ça c'est vraiment bon le ciel est pas du
tout
le résultat ça serait la même chose avec
la dinde ou ou le poulet
le produit un peu plus
un peu plus rapidement
et
les poissons aussi
orange le varech et les graines de
coriandre
une fois cuit à la vapeur on ajoute
simplement un peu de poivre de la fleur
de sel et de l'huile d'olive
bien doser la saumure occupe donc une
place importante on cuisine
[Musique]
c'est
intéressant
régulier
[Musique]